y
[Música]
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
prometió venganza contra los
responsables de los dos ataques mortales
a las afueras del aeropuerto de kabul
que cobraron la vida de al menos 85
personas entre ellos 13 soldados
estadounidenses suecia puso fin a la
misión de evacuación mientras que reino
unido anunció que entró en la etapa
final de su retiro de afganistán
y este viernes france24 dedica buena
parte de su programación a la situación
de las mujeres en afganistán sus
conquistas durante las últimas dos
décadas y los derechos que podrían
perder ahora que el grupo talibán retomó
las riendas del país analizamos la
situación de las que se quedan en ese
país ahora bajo el dominio talibán
y fueron liberados en nigeria decenas de
estudiantes que habían sido secuestrados
por hombres armados en una escuela
religiosa en el norte del país hace ya
tres meses más de 1000 estudiantes han
sido raptados desde diciembre 2020 y los
bandidos exigen rescates por su libertad
muy buen día para todos gracias por
continuar con nosotros en france24
blanco como siempre es un gusto
saludarlos comenzamos en afganistán
donde un día después de las dos
explosiones en las inmediaciones del
aeropuerto internacional de kabul que
causaron la muerte de al menos 85
personas incluidos tres soldados
estadounidenses continúan las últimas
evacuaciones por parte de los gobiernos
de occidente cientos de afganos
volvieron a regresar a las afueras de la
terminal aérea con la esperanza de
abandonar el país el pentágono advirtió
que la amenaza de nuevos ataques es
latente y habló de la posibilidad de
atentados con carros bomba e incluso
cohetes la casa blanca confirmó que unas
12 mil 500 personas fueron evacuadas el
jueves para un total de 105.000 desde el
pasado 14 de agosto el presidente joe
biden se refirió a los soldados caídos
en los ataques de ayer como héroes y
prometió venganza contra el estado
islámico en afganistán que reivindicó la
responsabilidad por las mortíferas
explosiones escuchamos parte de las
declaraciones del líder de la casa
blanca
2 grados
para aquellos que causaron el ataque y a
cualquiera que quiera hacer daño a eeuu
sepan que nosotros no perdonaremos no
olvidaremos
y perseguiremos y los haremos pagar
voy a defender los intereses de nuestro
pueblo con cualquier medida bajo mi
mando y suecia es el más reciente de los
países de occidente en anunciar que pone
fin a su misión de evacuación en
afganistán francia dijo ayer que
contener y asoló hasta este viernes por
la tarde y reino unido- que lidera junto
con eeuu la evacuación humanitaria
internacional ya cerró su centro de
operaciones en ese país y hoy terminará
su evacuación con las últimas mil
personas vamos precisamente hasta reino
unido con nuestra corresponsal luisa
pulido luisa muy buen día que reacciones
hay en reino unido tras el anuncio del
secretario de defensa de iniciar esta
fase final de la retirada
la población en general y diferentes
partidos políticos incluidos el
conservador del que boris johnson es el
jefe han criticado la decisión de
terminar su presencia en afganistán tras
20 años porque la han considerado un
fracaso pero también critican la crisis
que se ha generado en medio de esta
evacuación humanitaria está la molestia
en el parlamento británico que
recordemos la semana pasada fue
convocado de manera urgente
extraordinaria en medio de las
vacaciones del verano para una sesión
especial sobre afganistán que contempla
la posibilidad de crear una comisión
independiente para investigar qué hizo
el reino unido- en los 20 años de
ocupación en afganistán y por supuesto
toda esta crisis derivada de las
evacuaciones humanitarias una de las
posturas que más ha llamado la atención
y una de las más tristes ha sido la del
jefe del comité de relaciones exteriores
del parlamento toma tan en jan quien
también hizo parte de las tropas
británicas en afganistán y ha dicho que
ha sido la mayor crisis de rehenes que
el reino unido ha visto y ha lamentado
por supuesto que los afganos que
sirvieron por tantos años como
traductores de las tropas británicas en
terreno afgano no hayan podido ser
vacado se cree que un número aún
indeterminado entre 800 y 1500 afganos
no podrán salir de ese país
lamentable luisa ahora el g7 que
actualmente preside reino unido-
insistió en la necesidad de permitir
evacuaciones más allá del 31 de agosto
que esfuerzos realiza londres entonces
para que más personas puedan abandonar
afganistán más allá más allá de esta
fecha
preparando al país para la crudeza de
este momento en medio de la crisis
humanitaria que se vive en ese país el
ministro de defensa- ben wallace había
dicho que no todas las personas podrían
ser evacuadas por ello el reino unido-
ha pedido especialmente a los afganos
que traten de llegar a terceros países
como irán o pakistán para en esos
terceros países poder procesar todos los
documentos necesarios de quienes son
elegibles para venir a este país sin
embargo recordemos el talibán ya ha
dicho que no permitirá que nadie más
salga de su país por lo menos los
afganos por supuesto los medios locales
están llenos de historias desgarradoras
de intérpretes de las tropas británicas
que no podrán salir del país uno de
ellos dijo hoy estar escondido por temor
a que el talibán lo identifique lo
identifique y pueda ser asesinado además
dijo que no tiene los recursos para
salir del país como lo ha pedido el
gobierno por sus propios medios
cruda como usted lo dijo la realidad en
estos momentos de afganistán luisa
muchísimas gracias por su reporte tal y
como algunos temían el grupo estado
islámico en afganistán fue responsable
del atentado contra el aeropuerto de
kabul su auto denominado califato fue
desmantelado en irak pero el grupo
todavía tiene combatientes activos en
varios lugares de oriente medio y asia
en afganistán eso sí cadistas que se
quedaran enemigos del grupo talibán ya
han cometido varios atentados
se refieren a ellos mismos como estado
islámico de jorasán y xisca en honor al
nombre histórico de la región que
incluye partes de pakistán irán
afganistán y asia central
meses después de que declararan un
califato en irak y siria en 2014
luchadores desencantados de los
talibanes de pakistán y de militantes
afganos crearon la versión regional de
este grupo terrorista
el estado islámico se estableció en
afganistán contando con los que estaban
decepcionados con el talibán algunos
comandantes militares muy conocidos
prometieron fidelidad al estado islámico
fueron formalmente reconocidos por los
líderes centrales después de
establecerse en las provincias de kunar
la envergadura y stan en el noreste de
afganistán son enemigos declarados de
los talibanes ya que consideran que su
visión del islam no es suficientemente
dura
expertos en seguridad estiman que su
número de combatientes puede ir desde
los 500 hasta los 2.000 los ejércitos
europeos y de eeuu creen que los
integrantes del issys que operan gracias
a células secretas basadas en las
ciudades han logrado llevar a cabo
varios ataques de alto perfil en el país
por ende contacto inmediata en kabul ya
han realizado varios ataques en kabul
muchos mortales usando carros bomba
explosivos caseros y hasta bombardeos
con cohetes bomberos y dan como el
último ataque contra el palacio
presidencial antes de la victoria del
grupo talibán fue el estado islámico
quién lo hizo
en noviembre pasado atacaron la
universidad de kabul
también se cree que son responsables de
un atentado contra un pabellón de
maternidad en un barrio
predominantemente chiíta de la capital
habitado por la minoría hazara y en mayo
un carrobomba mató a 80 alumnas a pesar
de no controlar ningún territorio en la
región se sabe que el grupo se mantiene
activo y es peligroso y que busca
ampliar sus filas con yihadistas y con
personas descontentas con el dominio
talibán
y es que el regreso del talibán al poder
en afganistán preocupa en especial a las
mujeres que se quedan en ese territorio
esto por el temor de volver a vivir en
lo que experimentaron entre los años
1996 y 2001 cuando los talibanes ya
estuvieron en el poder un período
durante el cual sus derechos fueron
restringidos o se redujeron para
analizar esa situación quiero saludar en
este momento a mónica bernabé ella es
analista internacional y periodista del
diario ara además vivió durante casi
ocho años en afganistán mónica gracias
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 la cúpula
gobernante talibán aseguró que se
respetarán los derechos de las mujeres
bajo la ley de sharia y además
manifestaron su interés de conformar un
gobierno incluyente sin embargo
recomiendan a las mujeres tratar de no
salir de sus casas porque la base de su
formación no está capacitada para no
maltratar las le pregunto si logrará el
liderazgo talibán transmitir el mensaje
correctamente a sus bases y qué tan
creíble es esto además
bueno no se sabe muy bien lo que van a
hacer los talibanes hay que esperar a
que formen el gobierno se van a formar
un gobierno
que será islámico riguroso y que se
basada en la ley islámica pero no
sabemos qué normas establecerán esa ley
islámica y qué interpretación harán de
esa legislación islámica
hay que recordar que ya en los años 90
cuando los talibanes estuvieron
estuvieron en el poder ellos también
insistían de que respetaban los derechos
de las mujeres pero también
establecieron que las mujeres se tenían
que quedar en casa por razones de
seguridad es decir estamos en las mismas
estamos repitiendo el mismo discurso
ellos vuelven a decir que bueno que sí
que las mujeres pueden participar en la
vida pública pero que ahora como la
seguridad no es buena en afganistán que
es mejor que se queden en casa es decir
yo creo que
van a imponer pues pues eso que las
mujeres no puedan trabajar fuera de casa
no puedan estudiar y tal vez puedan
permitir que las niñas sí que vayan al
colegio pero bueno en afganistán y ahora
ya hasta antes de la llegada de los
talibanes al poder niños y niñas iban a
clases separadas y ahora en la comunidad
internacionales se encuentra en una
encrucijada por un lado las mujeres
piden que no se reconozcan al gobierno
talibán y por el otro un eventual
reconocimiento sería una herramienta de
presión política para exigir garantías
para las mujeres que deben hacer los
países de occidente ante este dilema
mónica
yo creo que los países de occidente
nunca les ha interesado la situación de
las mujeres en afganistán ahora todos
estamos escandalizados con lo que está
pasando en afganistán porque la
situación de las mujeres en afganistán
ya era dramática con la presencia de
tropas internacionales
en los niveles de violencia familiar en
afganistán son increíbles y eso se
conocía por parte de la cuenta de la
comunidad internacional y no se ha hecho
absolutamente nada no se hizo
absolutamente nada para presionar al
gobierno afgano a pesar que el gobierno
afgano dependía en esos momentos
totalmente al cien por cien de la ayuda
económica extranjera
y ahora claro ahora parte de esa
violencia familiar brutal se van a
encontrar con la violencia en las calles
es decir que no van a poder evitar
siquiera salir a la calle para poder
trabajar yo creo que la comuna
internacional va a hacer lo que siempre
ha hecho es decir actuar según sus
propios intereses no y no va a tener en
cuenta para nada ni a las mujeres
afganas ni creo yo al conjunto de la
población afgana ahora a mónica
brevemente cómo fue su experiencia
viviendo como mujer en afganistán
bueno como mujer extranjera en
afganistán y periodista por una parte
tiene desventajas y por otra parte tiene
desventajas las ventajas al ser un país
tan sumamente conservador y machista
pues consideran que no eres peligrosa e
incluso muchas veces te dejan entrar a
lugares que a un hombre no les dejarían
entrar yo me podía presentar en un
ministerio sin tener ninguna entrevista
concertada y por el hecho de ser mujer
pues decían ay pobrecita está fuera en
la calle bajo el sol esperando pues la
dejamos pasar sí
en otras ocasiones lógicamente si te
mueves en un país en el que básicamente
te encuentras hombres en todos los
escenarios y en la vida pública pues
lógicamente los riesgos los riesgos
sobre todo de abusos sexuales son mucho
mayores que en otro lugar mónica gracias
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto día nosotros continuamos en
nigeria donde grupos armados liberaron a
los alumnos restantes de una escuela
religiosa que permanecían secuestrados
desde hace tres meses el 30 de mayo 136
niños fueron raptados de una escuela
islámica en el estado a níger al noreste
del país los responsables de la escuela
afirmaron que 6 murieron en cautiverio
mientras 15 lograron escapar en junio
finalmente libres después de casi tres
meses en cautiverio es un gran alivio
para ellos y para sus familias reciben
alimentos antes de volver a casa el 30
de mayo unos 200 hombres armados
irrumpieron en la ciudad de tejina en el
noroeste del estado de níger abrieron
fuego y mataron a una persona luego
secuestraron a 136 alumnos de una
escuela y exigieron un rescate los
funcionarios de la escuela dicen que
seis de los estudiantes murieron
mientras 15 escaparon en junio no se
sabe con claridad cómo los niños fueron
liberados pero en agosto una persona que
había sido enviada a entregar un rescate
por la liberación de los alumnos resultó
secuestrado por los bandidos antes de
ser liberado con la exigencia de más
dinero por los niños más de 1000
estudiantes han sido secuestrados de
escuelas del norte y centro de nigeria
desde diciembre el gobierno ha sido
criticado por su incapacidad en hacer
frente a la crisis de seguridad en el
y despedimos el noticiero con un
homenaje a las mujeres caras
i
[Música]